based on the Smash Hit comic book by
Todd McFarland 1997 spawn is infamously
remembered today for its over-the-top
sometimes silly tone but the cast was
certainly taking it seriously John leis
amm's character for instance appears as
a nauseating bulbous Street punk in
bizarre facial makeup whose disgust for
humans is rivaled only by an appetite
for all things horrifying in one scene
the character eats a pizza covered with
live maggots like some other instances
Above This immediately led to a debate
among viewers about how real the scene
actually was eventually the conversation
got so loud that the actor himself had
to respond he tweeted in 2014 yes I did
eat maggots in spawn but I only
swallowed a few he followed It Up by
warning his fans not to try it at home
he said don't go there